up three to two Benjamin here is the
ultimate test for Jan he now has lost a
couple games uh oh he's playing a King's
game I was about to say can he rebound
or is he going to tilt he's going for I
need to win right now
exactly yeah well this is also what he
played against me and Tuttle Tuesday
this week when he was in a must win
situation in the last round we see
Magnus repeating I think there's also a
man is played against hikarakamura and
Norway chess you only going for a knight
of two he is still playing Super quickly
so perhaps he's looked at this before
the match
and Jan he returns to openings from his
childhood are these King's gambits he
plays the French defenses black he's not
afraid to play offbeat lines but the
problem with this particular opening is
White's King is in the center rookchate
earned an exclamation point going to the
open file maybe there's Rook G3 to come
and it just feels like black is the one
having the fun at least for the time
being
exactly yeah black is easy development
uh the bishop kind of move out of the
opponent E4 is tender so I don't know it
feels like this this king's Gambit has
backfired quite a bit I I remember also
in Norwich has when Hikaru tried to King
his Gambit against Magnus Magnus was not
in trouble for a single moment in the
game he knows quite well how to tackle
it
look at this position the G2 Pawn is
loose so the bishop on F1 can't develop
the E4 Pawn is attack and also pinned so
not only will there be tactics on the
Square and he was Queen of B3 I'm still
liking the look of Rook to G3 because
that also threads Knight takes D4 here I
have I just said it earlier but now it
carries an additional threat rookie
three checks gonna hurt this looks like
another potential one-sided game for
Magnus I think if he just goes on the
offensive Jan is going to be hurting
yeah I like this move from G3 that you
pointed out that it does threaten to
move Knight takes D4 it also introduces
this idea of Rook to E3 check and the
King has to perhaps go to D1 you can be
two but then you're in a pin so it looks
great so far for Magnus the materials
even white is completely tied up you
cannot develop a single piece and there
we see it rather The Rook to G3
it's so unfortunate for Jan he's pinned
along the third rank as king is stuck in
the center and when I mentioned Rook G3
several moves ago it's just because that
pawn is up on H4 one of the bad things
about pushing pawns is you give away key
squares so Black's Pawn structure looks
compromised with double f-pawns but
bedroom we see that you get counter play
around it whenever you have double pawns
you've opened files there's an open E
file there's an open G file there may be
these isolated pawns the f file but that
is not what's important it's King safety
and the aggressive intentions are all in
Black's favor
yeah and I already don't see what John
should do here Knight takes before is a
very clear threat perhaps you have to
move your queen but he's just moved it
so is he gonna move it again with like
Queen A4 but black just goes Bishop to
D7 but like almost has all of their
pieces into the game white only has
these two knights developed your king is
stuck in the middle it's very difficult
to develop Bishops so is yon perhaps
already a little bit until Robert
playing the king's Gambit was a sign to
me that maybe he was does he really
believe in the king's Gamepad that's
another question but against Magnus
Carlson I would not be playing such a
risky opening it's backfiring completely
as you mentioned the pin on the third
rank if the queen moves I don't even
know where he moved to if the queen goes
to C2 for example then Knight D5 into E3
is just another idea that I could go for
the pawn on e4 is pinned and oh my
goodness this looks miserable
this looks super tough for yon and what
really indicates that he is struggling
here is the clock usually Yawn is up on
time but now he's almost down one and a
half minutes on the clock he goes Knight
F3 hanging the pawn on e4 can Magnus
just take it
I actually like this decision he's gonna
swap Knights I believe and then he's
gonna try to tuck his King away there's
not another check in the position but
look at magnuscope Bishop E6 giving up
B7 he doesn't care about a single Pawn
he wants to go after that white king So
Benjamin it's all about timing and B7
should not be captured and look at this
variation Robert if Magnus grabs the
spawn on B7 Magnus ones grumpy to take
the queen and if you take a C7 there's
rocktex B2 and if you take there's Queen
E3 Checkmate so Magnus for sure cannot
take this Pawn but then where's he gonna
go with the queen
that is such a beautiful line if you
can't take on B7 because attack is The
Rook takes B2 check then you probably
just have to move your queen to D1 no he
plays Bishop to C4
can you I want to take it by Knight E5
but I'm not sure if it works it probably
does
yeah it I assume it does because you
kind of think the pawn that hangs up the
queen on C4 and if you take the Knight
you hang up on a G2 with devastating
effect so what do you do queen B5 but
maybe then just C6 followed by 93 or or
something yeah that looks crushing
Robert
it looks like it's going to be a swift
victory for Magnus he's doing the right
thing by calculating right now but
Bishop takes C4 followed by Knight to E5
it's very direct it's one attacking move
after another you hit the queen when the
queen gives you a check you hit the
queen again oh he castles Queen side
instead and I can't hardly blame him
Knight E5 is still a threat the white
king not very safe at all
at least this looks terrible for why
Brooke the G8 is coming attacking the
pawn on G2 Jan has still has not
completed his development and his King
is super weak on F2 so the king's gamut
has backfired tremendously
but King has been gamuted that King is
going to be stolen and black is going to
Checkmate it and it's going to be
another win for Magnus that would be
three in a row and I don't know how Jan
is going to bounce back from that but
King's Gambit is not the answer
and there we have to move Knight to E5
you cannot take the d-pawn you hang your
queen and again if you stick with the
Knight you hang the Palm in G2 so
there's nothing here for there's nothing
here for young I mean you're gonna have
to move to Queen then black can take an
F3 with a rook or with a knight and
black just gets a crushing attack and
blankets even up Upon A Magnus takes a
two-point lead
resignation